have you watched sounds of freedom the
movie I've read I don't want to walk
into the same shop I've read about it
what is it I've read a lot of things
about it what is it about exactly it's a
very popular movie now it's you haven't
watched sounds of freedom I actually
I've watched any movies to be honest but
no I don't uh do you think uh uh you
know the stats they quote and sounds of
Freedom which is as a father of four you
got one that's 11 about to be 12. I got
an 11 97 and a two-year-old so you know
uh uh um the mindset of a father where
when once you have a kid you're no
longer in one place you're always in two
places if you got one three places four
places five places so you're
continuously everywhere
um
they quote the stat of 20 million new
child pornography pictures have been
uploaded on the internet the last 12
months I'd say five thousand percent
increase in the last uh five years
um the fact that it's a 150 billion
dollar industry per year pedophilia uh
uh human trafficking the fact that you
can sell cocaine once but you can sell a
five-year-old child five to ten times a
day for 10 years depending on what the
age of the kid is and that this is a
crisis that is happening with minors
around the world with what's going on
around the border right now where kids
are coming unaccompanied this is a real
issue do you see that as a top five
crisis in America today it's a it's a
huge problem I have to I I didn't know
that's what the movie was about it's a
huge problem but I'll go beyond that I
mean there is a multi I don't want to
get out over my skis it's probably a
trillion dollar industry around
pornography of all types that is
completely I mean I see guys in these
rooms you know we have this this notion
of of the eighth and Ninth steps of
making amends and these guys who who are
addicted to pornography and the idea
that every time they're watching
pornography it's probably a human
trafficked or if someone's who's been
exploited or someone who's forced into
these things this is a this is a huge a
huge problem writ large I haven't seen
the program but it's it sounds as a
father it sounds it sounds hard you're
not equivocating porn with child sex
trafficking well what I'm saying is that
that that I I'm putting them in the same
category I'm putting them really I'm
putting them in the same place
consensual sex well hold on a second
hold on versus child sexual we have no
idea we have no idea about what consent
people have given whether whether
they're if you don't believe that porn
is exploitive of people
then I mean you you and I have a have a
different understanding I'm not saying
that all of it is I'm not saying I
highly disagreeing I'm not saying that
all of it is but I'm saying it's the
same
it is it's it's the same
General problem that we're looking at
stuff that's going on all the time
relatively out in front of us that we
don't really are thinking about the way
that it's corrosive to society surely
child children having sex is not the
same thing as adult having sex that's
true truly that's surely true
okay so that's sort of contradictory to
what you just said no I'm talking about
I'm expanding the conversation on
something I don't know very much about
to something I have I had more
experience I think the question was do
you think this is something that we
should be worried about do you think the
top five issues way way more than JFK's
assassination way more way way I don't I
don't disagree I I absolutely agree I
think to me it's even more than top five
but uh I agree in that area how much you
think we're doing to protect these kids
how because how often do we hear about
people getting you know Cod how often do
you hear about you know it happened at a
massive scale there's a lot of people
that are getting away with this I don't
know I I didn't I'm not really an expert
and I didn't I didn't see the movie but
yeah it sounds terrible I mean and the
movie's getting enormous amount of
attention so perhaps perhaps that's
that's the fulcrum that is needed to get
more done so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign